what advice would you give to young
people
today
they're in high school trying to figure
out what they're going to do with their
life maybe they're in college
what advice would you give how to have a
career they can be proud of or how to
have a life they can be proud of
so
the first thing is
find an ecology of practices and a
community that supports them
without involving you in believing
things that contravene are best
understood science
so that wisdom and virtue
especially how they show up in
relationships
are primary to you
this will sound ridiculous
but if you take care of that
the other things you want are more
likely to occur because what you most
want
is you what you want at when you're
approaching your death
is
what were the relationships
you cultivated to yourself to other
people to the world and what did you do
to improve the chance of them being
deep
and profound
relationships well that's an interesting
so ecology of practice so like
finding a place where a lot of people
are doing different things that are in
interesting interplay with each other
yes but at the same time is not a cult
like uh yes yes where ideas can flourish
now how the hell do you know
um
because actually in a place where people
are really excited about doing stuff yes
that's very ripe for cult formation
especially if they're awash in a culture
in which we have ever expanding waves of
[ __ ] yes precisely
so
try to keep away from the [ __ ] is
the advice yes no i mean i take this
very seriously and i was with a bunch of
people in vermont at the respond retreat
people rafe kelly was there
a bunch of people who have set up
ecology colleges and practices and
created communities
and
i have good reason to find all of these
people trustworthy and so we gathered
together to try and generate real deal
logos flow in distributed cognition
exercise the collective intelligence and
try and address that problem
both in terms of
you know metacurriculum that we can
offer emerging communities in terms of
practices of vetting how we will
self-govern the federation we're forming
so that we can resist gurlification
gratification of people or ideas both
yeah both some of us just get unlucky
some of us get unlucky and
we we all at
respond we all had a tremendous sense of
urgency around this
but we were trying to balance it about
not being premature
but
there it was going to i mean there's
we're going to produce a meta curriculum
that's coming in months there's going to
be a scientific paper about integrating
the scientific work on wisdom with this
practitioner-based ideas about the
cultivation of wisdom there's going to
be
projects about how we can create a
self-correcting vetted vetting system so
we can say to people we think this
ecology is legit it's in good fellowship
with all these other legit ecologies
we don't know about that one we're
hesitant about that one it it's not in
good fellowship we have concerns here's
why we have our concerns etc
and you may say well who are you to do
that it's like nobody but somebody's got
to do it right and that's what it comes
down to and so we're going to give it
our best effort
it's worth a try
you talked about the meaning crisis
in uh
human civilization but in your own
personal life
what has been a dark place you've ever
gone in your mind
has there been difficult times in your
life
where you really struggled yes
so when i left
fundamentalist christianity
and for a while i was just sort of
a hard-bitten atheist
um
the problem with leaving the belief
structure
was that i didn't deal with all the
non-propositional things that had gotten
into me
all the procedures and habits and all
the perspectives and all the identities
and the trauma associated with that so
you know i required therapy it required
years of meditation and tai chi
and i'm still wrestling with it but for
the first
four or five years i would
i i described it like this it was i i i
called it the black burning i felt like
there was a a blackness that was on fire
inside of me precisely because
the religion had left a taste for the
transcendent in my mouth but it had the
food it had given me yes food and square
quotes had soured in my stomach and made
me nauseous and that and the juxtapodish
the juxtaposition of those seemed like
an irresolvable problem for me
that was a very very dark time for me
did it feel
lonely when it was very bad it felt
extremely lonely
in the in
deeply alienating
the universe seemed absurd
and there was also
existential anxiety i talk about these
things for a reason i don't just talk
about them as things i'm pointing to i'm
talking about them as seeing in myself
and people i care you know
having undergone them and how
how they can bring you close to you know
self-destructive i started engaging in
kinds of self-destructive behavior so
the meaning crisis to you is not just
the thing you look outside
and and see
many people struggling you yourself are
struggling well but that's like that
that's in fact the narrative is i
struggled with it thinking it was a
purely
personal idiosyncratic thing i started
learning the cog sigh i started doing
the tai chi and the meditation i started
doing all this right socratic philosophy
and when i started to talk about these
pieces
i saw my students eyes light up and i
realized oh wait
maybe this isn't just
something
i'm going through
and then talking to them and then doing
the research and expanding it out it's
like oh
many people
in a shared fashion and also in an
individual lonely fashion
are going through meeting crisis
well we talked a lot about wisdom and
meaning and you said that the goal is to
love wisely so let me ask about love
what's the role of love in the human
condition
it's central
i mean it's even central to to to to
reason and rationality this is plato but
you know
spinoza
the most logical of the rationalists
you know
the ethics is written like euclid's
geometry but he calls it the ethics for
a reason
because he wants to talk about the
blessed life and what does he say
he says that ultimately reason needs
love because love is what brings reason
out of being entrapped in the gravity
well of ecocentrism
and murdoch iris murdoch said i think
really beautifully love is when you
painfully realize that something other
than yourself is real
escaping the gravity well of egocentrism
beautifully put a beautiful way to end
it john
you're a beautiful human being thank you
for struggling in your own mind with the
with the with the search for meaning and
uh encouraging others to do the same
and ultimately to learn how to love
wisely thank you so much for talking
today it's been a great pleasure lex i
really enjoyed it a lot thank you so
much
you